Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Quand on parle d’organisation économique,
généralement, on le résume
à deux fonctionnements :
le secteur privé,
dominé par les entreprises,
fonctionnant sous le système
de la concurrence
et qui a pour objectif le profit,
et le secteur public qui, lui,
est généralement issu de l’État,
organisé de manière institutionnelle
et qui a pour but
de développer un service public.
Mais est-ce qu’il existe un moyen
d’organiser l’activité économique
différent de ces deux modèles ?
Quand j’étais enfant, dans le Jura,
J’ai participé, à Épiquerez,
à des corvées communales.
En quoi ça consiste ?
Dans certains villages, dans le Jura,
il existe des pâturages communaux.
Les paysans du village
gèrent ce pâturage de manière commune.
On attribue à chacun des encrannes,
ce qui est une forme de droit
à y faire paître une vache,
un encranne étant une vache.
Ensuite, un cheval - ça dépend des
villages - ça peut être deux encrannes.
Et pour valider ce droit,
ils doivent faire une corvée.
Une fois par année, ils se retrouvent
dans le pâturage.
Il y a les enfants ;
c’est assez sympathique.
On fait des journées de travail,
et à la fin de la journée -
j’ai le souvenir d’une fois,
il y avait un orage le soir
et on s’est tous retrouvés dans une loge.
Et là,
il y avait les hommes du village, mais
aussi les femmes, tout le monde était là.
Et tout le monde a fait
le décompte des corvées.
Et combien valaient le travail
que chacun avait fourni dans la journée
pour valider la possibilité
d’y faire paître du bétail.
Quelle fierté quand on est enfant, quand
on apprend que, une journée de travail,
on lui accorde une valeur
d’un demi-encranne
alors que ton petit frère,
il ne vaut qu’un quart.
Je n’en avais pas conscience,
à l’époque,
mais je participais à une autre
manière d’organiser l’économie.
Ça s'appelle la gestion des communs.
Alors qu’est-ce que sont les communs ?
Ce sont des ressources partagées,
gérées et maintenues collectivement.
Ces biens peuvent être matériels comme...
une maison ou du matériel agricole.
Ça peut être des ressources naturelles,
comme un pâturage dans mon exemple.
Mais également immatériels,
comme un savoir.
Ici, vous avez l’exemple de Wikipédia,
qui est typiquement un commun.
Également un des exemples
qui a été donné juste avant moi :
le savoir-faire horloger
que Open Movement partage.
Il fonctionne comme un commun.
Les communs, ce n’est pas
quelque chose de nouveau.
Il y a encore dans quelques
villages dans le Jura,
et certainement ailleurs dans le monde,
des gestions communes de ressources.
Elles étaient généralisées
avant la Révolution française
et la Révolution industrielle.
Qu’est-ce qui a fait que
cette manière de fonctionner,
de faire tourner une économie
ou de gérer une ressource,
a petit à petit disparu ou est devenue
de plus en plus marginale ?
Ce qu’il s’est passé, c’est qu’au moment
de la révolution industrielle,
on a considéré que cette gestion
commune freinait le progrès,
empêchait de tirer profit
de ces ressources.
Et c’est pour cela que, en Angleterre -
on appelle ça le mouvement d’enclosure -
les terrains communaux ont été découpés,
séparés par des haies,
et ont disparu
au profit d’une forme de privatisation
cautionnée par le public.
Le privé et le public qui s’allient pour
faire disparaître les communs.
À la même époque,
une autre partie des communs -
Il y avait des pâturages, certes,
mais la propriété intellectuelle
n’était pas encore affermie.
En fait, les idées,
les œuvres d’art circulaient
et pouvaient se partager
quasiment librement.
Mais c’est à la même période
également qu’en fait,
s’est raffermi -
Ici, il y a l’acte
de la Convention française
contre les contrefacteurs,
où véritablement la propriété
intellectuelle s’affermit
et enclose également l’art.
Je vais encore vous raconter
une partie de mon histoire.
Au début des années 2000,
comme beaucoup d’entre vous, j’imagine,
j’ai découvert Internet.
J’étais adolescent.
Je jouais aussi aux jeux de rôles, qui
est une activité créative partagée.
Il se trouve que j’étais fan, comme
beaucoup de gens en France,
en francophonie, d'un jeu
qui s'appelait Agone.
Il avait un problème
parce que les ayants droit,
la maison d’édition ayant fait faillite,
ne se mettaient pas d’accord
sur la possibilité
d’en faire quelque chose.
Nous, les fans, on voulait plus de livres.
Ce qu’il s’est passé,
c’est que sur Internet,
il y en a qui faisaient leur petit site,
qui partageaient leurs textes,
il y a un forum qui s’est créé.
Finalement, ce qu’il s’est passé,
c’est que,
naturellement s’est constituée
une communauté
qui a géré des droits,
disons, en perdition,
et qui a permis ensemble de se mettre
d’accord sur le canon de cet univers,
de comment le créer,
ce qui est vrai ou faux.
Certains ne sont pas d’accord, alors -
les informaticiens connaîtront le terme -
on forke.
Et là, on a une dynamique qui est celle
de la reconnaissance par le travail,
par sa contribution
à un travail communautaire.
On a édité des livres.
On l’a fait discrètement parce que...
On n’en tirait pas profit.
Mais voilà, ça, c’est comment
émergent des communs sur Internet.
Parce que la réalité, c’est qu’Internet,
quand il s’est constitué,
a été constitué et a été géré
comme des communs.
Internet et l’informatique à ses débuts
sont issus d’une collaboration
scientifique entre universitaires.
Le consensus scientifique
est également un commun.
Et puis...
Internet a dans son ADN, comme
c’est une collaboration internationale
qui ne dépend pas d’un pays uniquement,
cette gestion des communs.
Et pour défendre tout ça,
dans les années 80,
Richard Stallman, qui a développé
le système d’exploitation GNU Linux,
formalise cela en créant une licence
qui permet
de protéger les créations libres
qui sont gérées par des communs,
d’empêcher qu’elles soient enclosées,
qu’elles soient privatisées
ou nationalisées.
Et il invente la licence GPL -
GNU Public Licence -
qui crée une nouveauté qui n’existait
pas encore chez les communs.
Parce que les communs, c’est quelque chose
qui se crée assez naturellement
dans les communautés, mais qui sont
très faibles pour se défendre.
La licence permet de se défendre
contre une privatisation.
Mais ce qu’il invente, c’est le copyleft.
le copyleft, c’est l’obligation que,
si on reprend quelque chose
qui est sous cette licence,
cela doit être également un commun.
Petit à petit, cette idée
progresse dans l’informatique.
Et au début des années 2000,
deux licences -
Tout d’abord, la licence Art Libre,
qui est comparable à celle de GNU GPL,
est créée en France.
Au même moment - certainement
en avez-vous entendu parler -
les Creative Commons,
C’est le début, en fait, de l’art libre.
Mais malgré tout, on le sait très bien -
certainement que vous utilisez internet.
enfin j’imagine bien -
ce qu’il se passe, ce qu’il s’est passé,
c’est que, malgré l’origine d’Internet,
malgré les précautions
qui ont été mises en place,
l’Internet que l’on a maintenant
est privatisé
par des énormes structures
qui sont les GAFAM.
Il y a toujours
des alternatives existantes
qui nous permettent d’échapper
à ces sociétés qui nous transforment.
À la base, les utilisateurs d’Internet
étaient des contributeurs.
Tout le monde contribuait,
tout comme les enfants ramassaient
quelques pierres dans le pâturage communal
pour contribuer à ce commun.
Ils nous ont transformés
en utilisateurs et en consommateurs.
Ils exploitent nos données.
Ils nous privent un peu de notre liberté.
Et ça a des répercussions
aussi dans l’art.
Avec Internet, les créateurs
indépendants ont fleuri.
Peut-être que vous suivez des youtubeurs.
D’ailleurs, le terme, youtubeur ?
Des vidéastes.
Des gens qui font de la création.
D’abord Ils le faisaient sur des blogs
Et petit à petit, ils ont été mis
dans des cases,
obligés d’utiliser des plateformes.
Les gens ne font plus de blogs,
ils tweetent,
ils font une story Instagram.
Et là, ils sont dépendants
de sociétés privées.
Là, je vous ai mis un exemple, c’est utip.
C’était une plateforme privée,
qui permettait de faire
des dons à des créateurs.
Début mai, elle fait faillite.
Tous les auteurs qui en dépendaient
se sont retrouvés du jour
au lendemain sans revenus.
Ça, c'est l'effet de la privatisation.
Moi, dans les années 2010, humblement.
je crée des jeux de rôles - j’ai continué
à faire ça, parce que j’aimais faire ça -
et je cherchais un moyen
de pouvoir monétiser ma création.
Et dans mes recherches, je suis tombé
sur quelque chose de fabuleux.
C'est Bitcoin.
Bitcoin, c'est un commun.
Il est géré exactement comme sur le forum.
On échangeait et on débattait
sur comment doit être le protocole.
Je suis historien, je n’ai pas les
connaissances techniques informatiques,
mais tout le monde peut en discuter.
On a un accès direct
avec les développeurs.
Je me suis retrouvé là
et je m’y suis reconnu.
Parce que Bitcoin,
c’est quelque chose de fascinant.
C'est la quintessence des communs.
Non seulement c’est géré
uniquement par la communauté,
c’est complètement indépendant
des États et des entreprises,
et il a un fonctionnement
qui intègre sa propre protection,
une sorte de super copyleft.
On ne peut pas copier Bitcoin
parce que Bitcoin est fondé
sur la construction petit à petit,
l’accumulation de calculs
qu’on ne peut pas reproduire,
qu’un État ou qu’une société,
ou même un groupement de sociétés,
ne peuvent pas reproduire.
Il se défend.
Non seulement il se défend, mais
en plus il s’autofinance.
C’est-à-dire que quand
vous contribuez par du calcul,
ou en y construisant quelque chose,
en fait, c’est un système de paiement
qui vous permet,
contrairement à utip,
de recevoir l’argent en sachant
que c’est quelque chose de stable.
Il est basé sur le travail,
la contribution,
tout comme dans les corvées communales.
L’effort est quelque chose
d’extrêmement mis en avant.
Lorsqu’on a l’art libre d’un côté,
et une solution de cette puissance qu’est
Bitcoin pour pouvoir être financé,
on peut faire des associations,
une collaboration entre les deux.
Avec l’art libre, avec le copyleft,
je peux mettre sous licence libre
un livre, un roman,
et quelqu’un d’autre qui a une belle voix,
qui sait faire des livres audio,
le reprend et le fait lui-même.
Et ensuite, possibilité,
quand on achète un livre audio,
il peut le faire sans demander,
sans devoir faire des contrats.
D’un autre côté, Bitcoin permet de faire
aussi des paiements sans friction.
Là, c’est un exemple.
Ce n’est pas de moi.
C’est un film qui a reçu des prix.
C’est un documentaire qui documente
la création d’une œuvre d’art à Paris,
qui reprend la chapelle Sixtine
dans un squat.
Il a été complètement financé
en utilisant Bitcoin
et d’autres protocoles
décentralisés comparables.
L’artiste également,
celui qui a fait la fresque,
se finance uniquement
par des dons en bitcoins.
Je vais encore vous parler
un peu de ma vie.
Après m'être lancé comme indépendant,
je suis devenu éditeur.
J’ai lancé ma maison d’édition,
PVH Editions.
On édite de la science-fiction,
de la fantasy.
On a une collection phare
qui s’appelle la collection Ludomire.
Ça faisait un petit moment
que ça me démangeait.
Je voulais libérer cette collection,
faire qu’elle soit sous licence libre.
Donc j’ai sauté le pas.
Au début de cette année,
j’ai fait l’annonce :
on a créé notre propre label,
Œuvre libérée.
Mais comme je vous l’ai dit,
juste le faire -
je n’avais pas grand risque,
le droit d’auteur ne sert que
les puissants, les gros labels, etc.
Mais je me suis dit : « On va aller
creuser un petit peu plus loin. »
Et là, on a imaginé un projet
qui s’appelle La Bookinerie,
qui sera une solution,
évidemment sous licence libre,
qui offrira la possibilité
d’héberger soi-même,
une solution pour monétiser
de la création,
pour vendre des livres,
faire des dons, du crowdfunding,
pour pouvoir aussi certifier ses œuvres,
et tout ça de manière intégrée.
Et on va le faire
pour ma maison d’édition.
Mais en fait,
l’Open source, ou le logiciel libre
pour être précis, c’est aussi le partage.
Et notre espoir -
c’est un projet qu’on porte ici
dans le canton de Neuchâtel,
avec une coopérative
qui s’appelle B2Bitcoin,
soutenue par le canton de Neuchâtel.
En fait, ce qu’on espère,
c’est qu’une bookinerie,
il y aura d’autres artistes dans le monde
qui vont se l’approprier pour se financer.
On pense particulièrement
dans les pays où le paiement électronique
est peu accessible, en Afrique,
où les artistes n’ont pas
forcément les moyens,
ni les financeurs,
de pouvoir faire du chapeau
ou vendre des œuvres.
Voilà.
Tout ça, si je vous le dis, si j’ai
voulu vous en parler aujourd’hui,
ce n’est pas pour vous dire qu’il
faut tout faire dans les communs.
Je veux juste dire que
depuis l’émergence d’Internet,
il y a une réémergence d’une ancienne
pratique qui est modernisée,
qui a des outils pour se défendre.
Il y a des protocoles, comme Bitcoin,
qui permettent des choses
dont vous n’avez même pas idée,
vous qui utilisez des banques.
Pour les entrepreneurs,
Je vous invite à réfléchir :
comment intégrer les communs
dans votre pratique professionnelle ?
Pour ceux qui sont plutôt
dans la politique :
comment intégrer les communs
dans une vision de la société ?
J’espère que cette
conférence vous a inspirés.
Je vous remercie.
(Applaudissements)